mais la mélodie et messieurs bonjour pas
un nuage sur paris aujourd'hui ça
n'était pas arrivé depuis 17 jours voilà
de quoi aviver les regrets de ceux qui
sont rentrés mais fait espérer à ceux
qui partent encore qu'ils trouveront le
même temps là où ils ont décidé de
passer leurs vacances
en fait monsieur météo il semble bien
que vos prévisions se confirment nous
sommes le dernier jour du mois de
juillet et le mois d'août doit commencer
sous le soleil à peu près partout
1er le 2 et le 3 août un petit épisode
orageux quand même à partir du 1er août
donc début de quelques orages sur le sud
ouest et les pyrénées mais bien entendu
sur tout le reste de la france
il fait beau le 2 août ces zones
orageuses à progresser vers l'ouest et
quelques orages tombe sur la moitié
ouest de la france mais surtout l'est
c'est à dire de la côte d'azur et de la
corse jusqu'au nord c'est le temps chaud
et beau qui prédomine enfin à partir du
3 août
ces zones orageuses attaque à ce
moment-là l'est mais le beau temps un
peu plus frais reprend sur l'ouest donc
un petit épisode orageux et trois
premiers jours ça devrait pas être trop
grave
avec à partir du 4 le retour d'un temps
plus frais mais sans orage avec beaucoup
de soleil
vous pouvez aller un peu plus loin et
nous dire ce que sera l'ensemble du mois
d'août et bien sans donner trop de
détails parce que bien évidemment on est
bien incapable on peut dire sans trop
s'avancer avec une grande probabilité
que le mois d'août risque d'être bien
meilleure évidemment que le mois de
juillet ça il faut bien dire évidemment
que le mois de juillet a été
catastrophique
il sera pas bien difficile au mois
d'août diète meilleur plus ensoleillé et
plus haut que moi j'ai donc un mois
d'août qui devrait être meilleur que
juillet s'est de nouveau aujourd'hui une
journée de grand départ plan primevère
sur les routes à partir de cet
après-midi trains supplémentaires dans
les gares trafic intense à orly et au
bourget si l'on en croit un sondage de
l'ifop publié aujourd'hui françois les
partisans de la limitation de vitesse
sont moins nombreux maintenant qu'ils en
ont fait l'expérience
le 30 juin 68% des français étaient pour
la limitation de vitesse
ils ne sont plus que 37,6 pour cent la
différence est donc très sensible un
détail qui a son importance
ce sont les français qui conduisent
beaucoup c'est à dire ce qu'ils font
au moins vingt mille kilomètres aux
parents qui sont les plus opposés à la
limitation de vitesse
en revanche le port obligatoire de la
ceinture de sécurité est approuvé par 68
% des français ils étaient soixante dix
pour cent il ya un mois donc là
l'expérience par est concluante
attention si vous prenez la route un
accident a fait cinq morts ce matin sur
une route de l'hérault le conducteur
d'une fourgonnette subitement déportée
sur la gauche il a heurté de plein fouet
une voiture qui venait en sens inverse
le conducteur de la fourgonnette et les
quatre occupants de la voiture tous de
la même famille ont été tués sur le coup
d'autre part aussi incroyable que cela
puisse paraître quatre personnes qui se
rendaient de lyon à paris par
l'autoroute ont disparu elles sont
partis de lyon
mercredi dernier il y a donc six jours
et elles ne sont toujours pas arrivés à
destination personne n'a de leurs
nouvelles toujours pour les
automobilistes si vous allez en italie
fait le plein avant de passer la
frontière
les pompistes italiens sont en grève et
vous risquez donc fort de tomber en
panne sèche sur les routes italiennes
en ce qui concerne les trains les
cheminots du service exploitation de la
gare saint charles à marseille sont en
grève jusqu'à demain matin 4 heures
certains trains arrivent à la gare de la
blancarde ou à aubagne d'autres
s'arrêtent même à avignon ou anime la
fédération de pêche de la haute garonne
a porté plainte contre x à la suite de
la pollution de la garonne constaté au
début du mois entre toulouse et agen
pour les responsables de la fédération
cette pollution est due aux déchets
rejetés par les usines qui ne respectent
pas les règlements anti pollution
sournoise la pollution à laquelle on ne
croit que lorsqu'on peut en mesurer les
effets plonge dans la tristesse et la
colère depuis une quinzaine de jours
les amis de la nature et les pêcheurs de
la fédération de pêche de la haute
garonne
ce tableau affligeant c'est celui de 400
tonnes de poissons tués tout au long
d'une centaine de kilomètres du fleuve
les responsables ne sont pas encore
connues mais le produit qu'ils ont
déversé du cyanure désigne tout
naturellement les industries riveraine
au prix moyen du kilo de poisson vif
nécessaire au repeuplement
c'est à 200 millions d'anciens francs
qu'on évalue le préjudice aussi dans un
élevage de truites de l'ardèche des
milliers de truites ont été empoisonnés
par le déversement de produits nocifs
provenant certainement d'une usine
c'est la deuxième fois en deux mois que
ce genre d'accident se produit la
plupart des ouvriers des usines l'ip
sont rentrés de vacances ce matin et ils
ont immédiatement assisté à une
assemblée générale au cours de laquelle
les délégués du personnel les ont mis au
courant de ce qui s'était passé pendant
leur absence je vous rappelle que c'est
cet après midi que le tribunal de
commerce de besançon doit prendre une
nouvelle décision à la suite du rapport
du syndic qui estiment ne plus pouvoir
poursuivre sa tâche d'autre part ce
matin également les cadres de l'usiné
ont refusé de pénétrer dans les locaux
étant donné la situation chez pechiney à
noguères la grève en est aujourd'hui à
son 40ème jour le comité de grève
envisage de demander au préfet des
pyrénées atlantiques de jouer les
monsieur bons offices l'industrie de
l'art graphique est en position de
faiblesse en france du fait de son
morcellement
dans ce secteur la concurrence étrangère
est particulièrement redoutable pour la
combattre cette chef d'entreprise ont
décidé d'unir leurs efforts une enquête
de gagner le dui premières décisions de
ses 7 p dg regrouper dans un même lieu
leurs entreprises
deuxième décision se rencontrer tous les
quinze jours mettre en commun les idées
les problèmes demander des conseils et
prendre des mesures dans l'intérêt du
groupe
ces mesures peuvent être des achats en
commun de matières premières afin
d'obtenir des réductions importantes ou
bien la création d'un bureau
d'information au service de la clientèle
mais en aucun cas ces mesures doivent
s'inquiéter sur la liberté des
entreprises d'une fusion il n'est pas
question de faire une fusion de nos
entreprises nous conservons notre
indépendance
le pdg est un individualiste protège sa
société l'ensemble de son système en
évitant ou en concurrençant directement
ses confrères ou ses collègues et de
vivre comme vous le faite en groupe
parce que cela lui impose nom s'impose
très peu de contraintes par rapport aux
avantages que ça amène le fait vivre en
groupe
bien entendu il à la première chose
c'est le partage des responsabilités non
pas individuelle de sa société
mais les responsables it et surtout
d'avenir sortent du marché surtout de la
profession les partager à 6,7 à ceyrat
branche et d'entreprise quel projet avec
vous dans l'immédiat mettre en place un
système et un réseau commercial en place
et immédiatement ensuite avoir des
accords financiers qui nous permettent
de faire face à un événement quelconque
au sein du complexe
150 machines 750 employés et techniciens
18 mille mètres carrés d'ateliers 90
millions de francs de chiffre d'affaires
il est encore trop tôt pour apprécier
les résultats au niveau économique
en revanche au niveau social plusieurs
avantages services de transport
formation continue sont communs aux
entreprises d'autres réalisations sont
possibles elles seront prochainement mis
sur pied une crèche un service
médico-social un restaurant élargi à
toutes les entreprises du groupe
pour l'instant ce restaurant n'existe
que pour une entreprise
et c'est là que tous les quinze jours
les pdg des jeunes ensemble ils sont
optimistes le présent et l'avenir leur
semble maintenant moins lourd c'est une
sécurité pour eux mais aussi pour leurs
employés une expérience intéressante à
suivre en tout cas les trois astronautes
de skylab ont décidément bien du mal à
s'adapter il souffre encore de malaise
et de nausées et si aux dernières
nouvelles ils vont un peu mieux ce n'est
tout de même pas encore très brillant
aussi les responsables du vol ont ils
décidé de repousser une nouvelle fois la
première sortie dans l'espace celle ci
n'aura lieu que j'ai dit mais si les
malaises continuer on dit à la nasa que
l'expérience pourrait même être
interrompue michel chevalet avant en
arriver à cette solution extrême vous
imaginez bien que les médecins de la
nasa veulent s'assurer de la gravité du
mal dont souffrent les trois hommes pour
l'instant donc seul la sortie dans
l'espace de guerriau telos ma sortie qui
ressemble à celle ci filmé lors de la
précédente mission est bien seul cette
sortie est à nouveau reportée d'un jour
elle aura donc lieu jeudi en attendant
la parole donc aux autorités de la nasa
pourquoi et bien parce que le mal de
l'espace qui se caractérise par des
vertiges des sueurs froides et des
nausées accompagnées parfois de
vomissements et bien ce mal de l'espace
et du un dérèglement du système
stabilisateur du corps humain et ce
système il est logé dans l'oreille
interne sous la forme de trois petits
canots semi circulaire ce soit en
quelque sorte les trois gyroscope qui
détecte les accélérations les
changements d'attitude du corps humain
aussi si nous tenons bien verticale
c'est grâce à mes un état d'apesanteur
que vous le voyez en ce moment ces
canaux ne fonctionne plus ou plutôt
fonctionne très mal si bien que le sujet
est atteint de vertige on note enfin que
chaque sujet réagi de façon différente à
la pesanteur qui plus est plus le cas
les grands et plus le mal est fort ce
qui reviendrait à condamner les grandes
stations orbitales de demain et
peut-être même des laboratoires comme le
skylab
dernière précision à l'heure actuelle on
note une légère amélioration de la santé
des trois hommes ce qui reviendrait à
dire que le programme pourrait se
poursuivre et pendant ce temps s'ouvre
aujourd'hui à bruxelles une conférence
spatiale européenne les représentants de
douze pays y participent ou dit michel
chevalet que c'est la conférence de la
dernière chance la der des der oui à
bruxelles et bien on essaye de sauver
l'europe spatiale on essaye de mettre
sur pied une bonne fois pour toute un
programme spatial cohérent un programme
qui se présente sous deux vols
le premier est bien c'est la
construction d'une super refusé d'un
lanceur lourd le l3 est ce que vous
découvrez en ce moment c'est d'un projet
cher à la france
il permettrait de mettre en orbite les
satellites de télécommunications
européen
l'autre projet vient c'est le space lab
autrement dit le laboratoire spatial en
laboratoire qui serait embarquer dans
les soutes de la fameuse navette
américaine
donc actuellement à bruxelles eh bien on
est à chercher des sous pour financer
les deux programmes le coût 4 milliards
de nouveaux freins et lorsque l'on a
fait les comptes la dernière fois le 12
juillet dernier
eh bien on était donc loin du compte
alors rendez vous ce soir à bruxelles
pour savoir si oui ou non leur au
spatial existera les négociations sur la
réforme du système monétaire
international semble être sorti de
l'ornière c'est du moins l'impression
qui prévaut après la première réunion
hier à washington du comité des vins
patrice duhamel quelles sont les raisons
qui tout à coup peuvent justifier cet
optimisme soudain vient en effet claude
guillaumin et le bio mais il ya bien
longtemps qu'un tel optimisme n'avait
pas soufflé sur une conférence monétaire
les propos encourageants tenus à
washington appelle je pense deux
observations d'abord pourquoi cela est
bien chacun est conscient que la
situation actuelle ne peut durer plus
longtemps
le dollar est malade la lire italienne
et la livre britannique bat de l aile
en revanche al'inverse le market en trop
bonne santé et attire trop de
spéculateurs ces déséquilibres qui
freinent le développement du commerce
sont la marque le système monétaire mis
en place en 1944 n'existe plus donc au
delà de leurs divergences les
partenaires occidentaux ont tous intérêt
à construire en commun une nouvelle
organisation monétaire
hier donc à washington des progrès
sensibles ont été accomplis au prix il
faut le dire de quelques concessions
mutuelles et pour monsieur schmitt le
ministre allemand des finances on peut
même s'attendre à un accord sur une
réforme de fond au printemps de l'année
prochaine cette réforme qu'on prendra
sans doute la création d'une nouvelle
monnaie étalon ce que les techniciens
appellent droits de tirage spéciaux et
qui serait en schématisant un cocktail
des monnaies actuelle la seconde
observation c'est qu'il ne faut quand
même pas faire preuve d'un optimisme
exagéré
la négociation ne fait que commencer on
en est à définir les grands principes et
il est probable que la discussion sera
plus difficile quand on en viendra à
l'application et puis ne l'oublions pas
deux dossiers brûlants votre corps
occupé au cours des prochains mois les
ministres des finances c'est d'abord le
règlement de la crise monétaire actuelle
qui n'est pas terminée le dollar 20
avait un peu mieux mais il faut quand
même qu'ils remontent à un niveau
supérieur
et puis le second dossier c'est le
fameux nixon raul les grandes
négociations commerciales europe etats
unis japon qui s'ouvre solennellement à
tokyo en six semaines mais qui ne
commenceront sérieusement qu'au cours de
l'année 1974 sans doute au printemps ou
à l'été
donc si l'optimisme est de rigueur à
washington et si les grandes les grands
principes se traduisent dans les faits
de l'année prochaine cette année 1974
sera sans doute décisive elle permettra
peut-être la mise en place d'une
nouvelle organisation monétaire
et puis également un début de
libéralisation plus importantes du
commerce mondial 245 militaires
canadiens ont pris l'avion ce matin à
saigon ils rentrent chez eux ce départ
est la conséquence du retrait des
représentants canadiens de la commission
internationale de contrôle du
cessez-le-feu au vietnam
les soldats et officiers de l'armée
canadienne qui constitue l une des
quatre délégations de la commission
internationale de contrôle et de
surveillance au vietnam ont
définitivement quitté saigon hier soir à
destination du canada
ils ont été salués par les trois autres
délégations celle de la pologne de la
hongrie et de l'indonésie ainsi que par
les autorités sud vietnamienne en a
cependant remarqué qu'aucun représentant
du grp n'était présent pour assister à
leur départ
le canada avait décidé de rappeler son
contingent parce qu'il estimait que le
cessez-le-feu n'était pas respectée et
que la commission de contrôle était
totalement inefficace d'autre part
hongrois et polonais critique est
constamment les canadiens pour avoir
promis selon eux l'accent sur les
violations du cessez-le-feu et les
accusés même parfois de partialité à
l'encontre du viet congs avec leur
départ la commission de contrôle est
momentanément paralysé
en attendant qu'un autre pays soit
désigné pour remplacer le canada a sego
parmi les pays qui seraient du tout
intéressé on cite l'iran le brésil et
les pays bas
arrivé au vietnam dès le 28 janvier
dernier les canadiens ont eu l'un des
leurs tués et deux autres prisonniers du
viet cong but en quinze jours le chef de
la délégation canadienne en baissant les
couleurs de son pays a déclaré nous
vénérons ce drapeau comme le symbole de
ce que nous avons essayé le faire
un nouvel épisode dans la sphère du
watergate monsieur haldeman l'ancien
secrétaire général de la maison blanche
a révélé devant la commission d' enquête
du sénat que le président nixon l'avait
autorisé à écouter les enregistrements
de deux conversations qu'il avait eues
lui nixon avec monsieur john dean
l'ancien conseiller juridique de la
maison blanche
d'autre part le président nixon
maintient son refus de remettre tout
enregistrement à la commission comme
prévu les dirigeants des pays
socialistes d'europe se sont réunis
autour de monsieur brejnev sur les bords
de la mer noire les soviétiques qualifie
ce sommet de rencontre amicale à l'ordre
du jour l'avenir de la coopération entre
pays frères et les problèmes de
l'actualité internationale sans autre
précision résultats définitifs du
référendum en grèce 3 millions huit cent
soixante dix mille 124 lecteurs soit 78
4 % ont dit oui à la république 1
millions 64 milles 320 ont répondu non
une information sportive le footballeur
malien salif keita a fait ses adieux
hier soir au football français puisqu'il
jouera la saison prochaine en espagne à
valence dans un match amical qui
opposait à cannes des joueurs africains
jouant en france au club local
kate a voulu se faire regretter il a été
le meilleur joueur sur le terrain
les amateurs de westerns ont l'embarras
du choix cet été à paris les
distributeurs doivent penser comme moi
d'où on va surtout au cinéma pour se
détendre
parmi ces westerns le dernier signé
robert aldrich un spécialiste qui
s'intitule fureur apache
vous allez le voir on y joue beaucoup de
witch hunters mais aussi d'armes plus
subtile croirait voir un film vieux de
20 ans avec fureur apache le nouveau
film de robert aldrich
on nous y montre d un bien cruel le
pouvoir rouge ne sera pas content une
spectateurs qui s'en moque il trouvera
un certain plaisir il faut bien qu'il y
ait un méchant dans un western rouge ou
blanc voit pourvu qu'on tire et il est
bon d'y retrouver burt lancaster en
vieux coureur de prairies mais les
partisans du western progressiste seront
très très fâché
échec
j'habite
à
vous m'aurez pas pouvoir yeux par suite
marie cadet
là je l'aurais je descendrai avant
qu'ils ne descendent n'aurai pas ma
ferme dans les bois
pas loupé
oxygène maison pour
au très beau ça viole au prélat
seigneur vous méritez toutes les
louanges et toute la gloire mais c'était
une ruse de sioux part dans d'apache
c'était eux qui sonné le clairon le
fermier sera brûlé vif nous parlions
tout à l'heure de la pollution sur la
garonne et nous allons y revenir dans
notre magazine on estime à cinq millions
le nombre de français qui pratiquent la
pêche à la ligne et pendant les vacances
ils sont encore plus nombreux mais en
raison de la pollution certains poissons
comme la truite le saumon par exemple
sont menacées de disparition
est ce que cette rivière est très pollué
monsieur très pollué nom peut pas parler
de vraiment demande pollution dans
l'appart mais il faut lui surtout les
heures de pointe des pollutions
citoyenne mais mon poste j'ai fait
l'ouverture c'est pas trop mauvais mais
alors le principal c'est de tomber dans
les rivières qui sont pas vraiment peu
lui et moi je vais à bray sur seine
c'est à peu près potable mais d'ici une
dizaine d'années ça va peut être pouvoir
se polluer partout maintenant on évolue
est bien gros veau ou que ça veut dire
plus exactement sur les rivières sont
toujours sales temps le temps j'étais
propre dans le temps clair et tout
envoyer un message twitter c'est pas du
poisson ce matin aux yeux non j'ai fait
une ablette c'est par accident
y'a plus rien et pourquoi je sais rien
la pollution
qu'est ce que vous appelez pollution
coli shanghai est différente genre de
pollution vous avez d'une part les
usines qui doivent normalement avoir un
bac de décantation qui ne l'ont pas
parce que ça coûte trop cher et si on
les oblige à faire un bac de décantation
qui coûte très cher ils disent moi je
suis obligé de mettre tout le personnel
en chômage parce que je peux pour y
arriver
d un autre côté vous avez tous les
produits que les cultivateurs j'ai rien
contre eux répondent pour avoir de
belles récoltes
quand il arrive un orage tout ça ça va à
la rivière et puis c'est tout
ils sont 5 millions de français à pêcher
le long de nos rivières 5 millions qui
ont acquitté le timbre piscicole plus un
droit pour lancer leur ligne sur le
cours d'eau de l'anchois que ce soit
pour une journée à moi ou une n 5
millions à être déçus inquiète sa mort
de moins en moins nos rivières sont de
plus en plus polluée on hésite souvent à
consommer ces prix à l'état sauvage de
gros poissons a pratiquement disparu
certaines espèces courantes atteintes
par des virus sont malins bien sûr il ne
faut pas généraliser
il y à des exceptions la situation de la
pêche au début des vacances cette année
comment ça se passe et bien la situation
de la pêche est variable bien entendu
selon les régions
en ce qui concerne le saumon l'allier a
été excellent pour la truite dans
l'ensemble la situation est favorable
sauf quelques rivières qui sont
atteintes par la maladie
car évidemment sur l'ensemble de la
france les normes problème et le
problème de la pollution sur le plan
tweet c'est une année moyenne
seules deux régions ont connu
des avaries les régions calcaire les
régions qui vont du jura à la normandie
il s'est propagé depuis plusieurs années
une maladie que l'on appelle syndrome
mycosique qui est une sorte du dn on ne
sait pas très bien les chercheurs sont
sur cette question qui a touché les gros
géniteur ce qui n'empêche en ce moment à
l'époque de la mouche je puis vous en
parler puisque j'en reviens y est
nous faisons encore de gros poissons
mais les gros sujets ont disparu comment
lutter vous contre cette pollution bien
tout le monde s'y met les principaux les
principaux lutteurs sont les fédérations
de pêche et de pisciculture et le
conseil supérieur de la pêche en liaison
étroite avec l'administration et les
services spécialisés qui sont les
techniciens et les laboratoires qui
s'efforcent une maladie est détectée sur
une rivière est signalé par une amp est
une fédération de savoir quelle est la
nature du virus et comment le combattre
si l état sauvage le poissons de nos
rivières disparaît peu à peu
il est remplacé par le poisson d'élevage
les pisciculteurs élèves dans bassin
fermé des alevins qui sont ensuite
rejetés en rivière
après dix endroits étudie encore faut-il
que les bassins alimentés en eau de
rivière ne soit pas humaine ponyo vous
avez combien de truites ici environ de
la truite adultes avec les géniteurs
enfin la truite adultes c'est à dire
qu'il n'est pas besoin de bras il y en a
bien pour 150000 vous avez cent
cinquante huit truites pour une sonnerie
vient alors cette nénette qui fait
combien km et 20 km pour moi de partir à
la pêche à la faute et sans recours à la
perche touristique à la social qu'a
énorme pour une petite rivière non
c'était bien le nombre de pêcheurs aux
mets du poisson nous tous les jours ce
poisson qui est né dans son élément qui
grandit dans son élément et kir
déversait dans son élément
alors le poisson ne pas est plus un
climat t il des valent beaucoup moins il
se tient mais il est mieux cette rivière
elle est à la merci d'une pollution
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre
pisciculture à ce moment là elle a
souhaité à la merci d'une pollution
accidentelle ou de la malveillance
alors maintenant depuis quelques mois
j'ai contracté une assurance qui
garantit toute la pollution
je crois que vous avez un autre moyen de
protection qui consiste éventuellement
isolé dans le laboratoire
désolé c'est à dire que j'ai deux
alimentations 2nd source et l'eau de
rivière alors dès qu'on peut sentir la
pollution qu'on voit quelques déjà
célèbre tout ce qui est dans laboratoire
peut être sauvé en laissant la source
si on enlevait nous de rivière sans
parler du virus quelles sont les formes
courantes de pollution pollution que
vous avez des pollutions par les cyanure
par des accidents des camions s'ils s'en
versent il avait une influence
d'insecticide à ça si les cultivateurs
doivent employer ces insecticides sur un
domaine c'est bien mais faut pas
dépasser les doses prescrites ci a
produit certes ça va ça reste sur la
terre et le jour qu'à une grosse pluie
toutes les eaux descendre sur la rivière
et ça pollue ça fait crever le poisson
m'avait parlé aussi d'épandage par
hélicoptère je crois en ce oui c'est
déjà arrivé aussi que quelquefois l
hélicoptère vole trop bas où il fait son
travail sans s'occuper des vents alors
si les vents sont défavorables tout
vient surnom sur l'élevage sur les
bassins d'élevage et puis ma foi il ya
quelques années j'ai eu un bassin comme
ça presque anéantie
le saumon ce poisson le plus beau
peut-être de nos rivières peut atteindre
un mètre cinquante et peser jusqu'à 18
kg seulement guano le second et d'un
voyage n'est en eau douce il devient
ensuite poisson au salé avant de
redevenir poissons d'eau pour se
reproduire et remonte en effet jusqu'à
sa rivière d'origine un voyage périlleux
il doit éviter les filets des pêcheurs
professionnels les mouches artificielles
de 3000 amateurs
il doit venir à bout des obstacles dont
certains des barrages sont
infranchissables
un périple qui lui fait aussi de la
pollution mais l'espèce en danger
le saumon est quand même une espèce est
témoin d'une période qui est en train de
disparaître
c'est l'impression qui demande une eau
pure c'est un poisson d'âge presque
préhistorique et c'est à ce titre je
pense que la direction de la protection
de la nature et de l'environnement
s'inquiètent beaucoup de protéger
l'espèce à part ça c'est aussi un
poisson qui ne se nourrit pas en eau
douce
donc ils apportent une richesse qu'il a
prélevé dans la mer et il la met à la
portée de nos pêcheurs le long des
bassins fluviaux qu'il fréquente
essentiellement les bassins de l'adour
bassin de l'allier est différent petit
fleuve côtier de bretagne
il n'y a pas qu'un problème des
migrations malheureusement pour les
migrations je pense pourrait se résoudre
au prix de quelques sacrifices
économiques
maintenant il ya le problème du pêcheur
le plus gros prédateur du saumon
actuellement c'est le pêcheur tous les
pêcheurs sont concernés d'abord les
pêcheurs de saumon auquel la
réglementation actuelle permet de
prendre pratiquement autant de saumons
qui veulent pourvu qu'ils aient payé
leur supplément de permis et pourvu
qu'il le pêchent légalement et en dehors
des réserves seraient souhaitables n'ont
qu'un pêcheur qui se respecte qui va
pêcher le saumon soient satisfaits quand
il apprit mettons quatre ou cinq saumon
dans sa saison qu'il en laisse pour les
autres qui l'enlève pour se reproduire
évidemment c'est très difficile à faire
respecter ça nécessiterait je pense un
système d'agrafage chaque saumon étant
obligatoirement munies par le pêcheur
d'une estampille aussitôt sorti de l'eau
et le saumon devraient pas voyager sans
son estampille
il faut noter des initiatives heureuses
au milieu de la réserve naturelle du
mercantour à saint martin vésubie dans
les alpes maritimes
la municipalité a entrepris
l'aménagement d'un parcours de pêche
moddeurs 5 km de ce cours d'eau le port
et ont ont été nettoyés les
empoisonneurs ici à première vue il n'y
aura jamais de pollution
je suis maintenant le directeur de ce
parcours de pêche du mourillon et nous
l'avons organisé ici en accord avec la
fédération et avec son président
monsieur kermesse
il se compose actuellement du lac du
boréon qui est ici à vos pieds qui est
ouvert à tous les pêcheurs
ensuite une zone de réserve ils
réservent complète longue de 500 mètres
puis une un parcours pour toutes les
cannes lancer ou quel choc où environ 2
km et enfin se termine le parcours à la
mouche qui a plus de deux kilomètres le
l'ensemble doit nous faire actuellement
5 km
on n'a pas ça se passe on nous en
demande une carte chez vous puis on part
dans la nature ou citerai contre lui
commence assez faisons rien nous nous
basons sur l'autocontrôle des pêcheurs
le contrôle pêcheurs arrivé au chalet
d'accueil nous lis des livres ont une
carte journalier comme celle ci cette
carte journalière comporte un certain
nombre de petits coupons le pêcheur peut
aller pêcher dans la rivière maintenant
dans le parcours et à chaque prise qu'il
va conserver il découvre un petit poupon
si l'on prend des supplémentaire le soir
il passera également que chalet
d'accueil pour le contrôle des gardes
tout le long du parcours sont à
disposition sur le plan policier ont ici
heureusement il n'y a pas de problème il
n'y a pas de problème parce que comme
vous avez pu vous en rendre compte
il n'y a aucune construction dans au
pays et il n'y en aura jamais nous
procéderons dans les années à venir à un
aménagement touristique de ce site par
la création de parkings de dissuasion
les voitures seront cachés la façon que
les gens puissent retrouver ici un air
vraiment miliciens ou n'y aura pas du
tout pollution mais notre mensuel
mais un parcours modèle ne règle pas le
problème dramatiques de la pollution de
l'ensemble de nos cours d'eau
le dollar est plus ferme aujourd'hui sur
la plupart des places européennes
notamment à la bourse de paris d'autre
part gérard vidal hanche
la fédération des émirats du golfe
persique a décidé de créer un pool
monétaire fondé sur l'or
oui claude desbiens le dollar ce matin à
côté près de 4 francs 20 la parité
officiel est de 4 francs soit 100 donc
on a tout de même comblé une partie de
la baisse de la monnaie américaine
puisque cette monnaie des tombes et
rappelez-vous en dessous de 4 francs à
390 on parle même d'une valeur du dollar
de 440 à 450 pour septembre mais ceux ci
sont des prévisions des pronostics c'est
dire que tout de même l'atmosphère s'est
bien et dégage et la bourse de paris où
aujourd'hui il ya eu si je puis dire
beaucoup de touches sur les valeurs
françaises sur les valeurs de croissance
je dirais même qui est presque une pêche
miraculeuse car les hausses comme vous
le voyez sont sensibles sur l'ensemble
des valeurs
pourquoi la fédération des émirats du
golfe persique veut-elle renoncer au
dollar pour la parité de ces monnaies et
bien parce que il ya eu évidemment un
dévergondage sur les monnaies et surtout
sur le dollar le pétrole est vendu en
dollars et les émirs qui produisent
environ 80 à 100 millions de tonnes
je voudrais une monnaie beaucoup plus
stable pour leurs transactions
commerciales mais bien entendu il n'est
pas question pour l'instant de changer
de mener pour la vente du pétrole
voici des eaux sur les valeurs de
croissance 7% par exemple de haut sur
moulinex 4% sur carrefour vraiment la
séance est tout à fait remarquable ce
matin toujours dans le domaine du
pétrole
une société française aura frepe en
indonésie a découvert un gisement de
perte de pétrole qui sera mis d'ailleurs
une exploitation dès novembre chez à sa
production initiale sera de l'ordre de 1
million 500 mille tonnes
c'est encore peu de chose mais c'est
tout de même
1 d et en ce qui concerne les pétroles
d'aquitaine le relèvement du prix du gaz
lors de 4 % va augmenter de 40 à 50
millions la capacité bénéficiaire des
pétroles d'aquitaine
cette augmentation va permettre à la
société de développer encore son effort
d'exploration dans le monde et surtout
un effort de diversification puisque le
gisement de lacq est en voie d'expulsion
des os et bien il y en a eu en dehors
des valeurs de croissance dont les
affaires de distribution d'eau les a
faits les valeurs métallurgiques et
également les affaires de construction
de routes comme la chimiques routière du
laboratoire pharmaceutique comme roussel
uclaf carrefour 4100 4170 4140
maintenant plusieurs courts qui dénote
une activité tout de même assez
importante
ce matin même saint gobain qui gagnent
de francs à 192 les autres valeurs
progressent du même le commerce avec
l'est se développent une étude du
ministère des finances a montré que
depuis 65 nous échange avec l'ess avait
augmenté de 143 %
ceci est important pour toutes les
affaires de biens d'équipement qui
peuvent exporter dans ces pays nous
avons pris maintenant pratiquement la
deuxième place après l'allemand valeurs
étrangères surtout en hausse sur les
valeurs allemandes et sur petrofina qui
gagne 5 sur l'or et bien 15 1735 25
francs de mieux sur hier ce sont
pratiquement les mêmes cours en tous les
cas c'est un cours inchangé sur le
napoléon à 121 francs 30
enfin un mot sur les sicav qui place les
capitaux donc en action des progressions
tout de même qui sont intéressants
depuis le début de l'année si la france
par exemple
géré par le crédit lyonnais a gagné près
de 13% et par n'unit qui est gérée par
le crédit agricole
la progression est de l'ordre de 3%
voilà pour la bourse claude guillaumin
avec une excellente séance à vous eh
bien je souhaite de bonnes vacances à
tous ceux qui partent aujourd'hui à tous
un bon après midi
merci de votre attention